>> All right, so here, here is, here's a table of
examples with the input pattern and the actual output pattern of the
hypothesis we're looking for. But I'm not going to tell you the
hypothesis, you have to figure it out. So the way you're going to
do that is, by figuring out for each variable, does it
appear in the conjunction in its positive form, in its negative form
or it's not there at all? For example if you want to
say the hypothesis is X1 and not X5, you would write something
like X1 and not X5, and the other ones are all absent.
And just to be clear Charles, I, I've picked this particular set
of examples so that, you particularly, Charles Isbell PhD, would have the
best chance of figuring out the hypothesis with the smallest number of examples.
>> I appreciate that.
>> Go.